[Music]  we are at cube con EU 2018 the first  cube con of the year when I first heard  about the kubernetes project I was like  oh my god this is amazing this is  exactly what I needed this is a four  thousand people event it's amazing to  see the growth since then when I joined  the kubernetes project there were four  other contributors I'm now at the fifth  Yukon that I personally intended there's  over 4300 attendees here and we've gone  from the initial view of us building the  project to over 11,000 individual  contributors we are definitely going to  see more and more attendees and as we  see the growing of coop client we see  from focusing more on contributors and  to focusing more and more on the  ecosystem and also the users  [Music]